The
practice of referring to “excessive bureaucratic
rigmarole” as red tape dates back more than
400 years to the court of the Holy Roman Emperor
and King of Spain, Charles V (1500-1558).
As heir to three of Europe’s most powerful
dynasties (Habsburg, Valois-Burgundy and Trastámara),
at the height of his power, Charles’ empire
stretched from Spain in the west to Hungary
in the east, and from the Netherlands in the
north to Sicily in the south.
In addition, Charles had significant holdings
in the New World, and an enormous administration
to manage his vast empire.
At the time, administrative documents were
bound in some fashion, either with rope, string,
ribbon or cloth.
Sometime during the early 16th century, in
order to distinguish the most important documents
that required immediate discussion at the
highest levels of government (such as the
Council of State), from those of less significance,
Charles’ ministers began tying important
papers together with red string or ribbon.
Seeing the efficacy of such a system, the
method was soon adopted across Europe, and
in fact, England’s Henry VIII used red string,
ribbon or cloth to secure the petitions he
sent to Pope Clement VII requesting annulment
of his marriage to Catherine of Aragon in
1527.
Note that well before this time, tæppe had
been an Old English word that meant “narrow
strip of cloth used for typing, measuring,
etc.” and its use dates back to at least
the late 16th century.
So, while it’s not clear that Henry’s
court called it red tape, it is possible.
As for the term “red tape,“ reference
to this string for important papers dates
back to the late 17th century where it was
written in Maryland Laws: “The Map . . . upon
the Backside thereof sealed with his Excellency’s
Seal at Arms on a Red Cross with Red Tape.”
The Oxford English Dictionary dates its current
meaning to 1736 and John Hervey’s Poetical
Epistle to the Queen: “Let Wilmington, with
grave, contracted brow, Red tape and wisdom
at the Council show.”
Another early instance of its metaphorical
meaning is seen more clearly in Catherine
Gore’s Stokeshill Place (1837): “My dear,
you mistake John Barnsley.
Dearly as he loves a bit of red tape, you
never saw him try to inspire any other man
with the love of business.”
Shortly thereafter, the term became widely
used, including in Charles Dickens’ David
Copperfield (1849-1850): “Britannia, that
unfortunate female, is always before me, like
a trussed fowl: skewered through and through
with office-pens, and bound hand and foot
with red tape.”